it smells really bad genuinely doesn't
smell nice that's all right everyone for
sure that's going to be on me you know
don't dis our mangoes us
pepper mango this is crazy
there's no way i can eat that
yo it's aj tracy and this is snack wars
trinidad versus uk for the lad bible
obviously we're doing trinidad because i
myself am a british trinity citizen
boom yeah okay all right look look first
of all you see this
the mandem when i say the mandem i mean
people like me we do not drink this this
is not for us
you see this now on my every every
thing i love on everything i love this
one of my favorite drinks in the whole
world this is soul fire this is fire
that's what i wanted to see to represent
chilidog shandy carob
it's really nice it's lovely refreshing
yeah this is a great drink i would
highly recommend this
and this is already one i can tell you i
can tell you this is already one
this this is a bit crazy but i'm gonna
drink some just for you because that's
what we do here right
okay it's got a nice fizz to it smells
right smells like a beer
tastes like a beer but it's flat so no
it's a
it's a no from me all right let's see
what we've got here
oh it's a treat this one's a treat this
one
[Music]
banging banging this is banging this
this string actually brings my memories
i've had this a lot of times in trinidad
it just reminds me of like being there
yeah man lovely lovely drink i think
hands down on trinidad as well this one
i think if i didn't like this one
i'll probably they'd revoke my trailer
that like i wouldn't be allowed to be
from anyone like yeah this is great
though
oh gosh what we got here this is mad
peppa mango i've actually had this as
well not a fan
i'm not a fan i'll be honest
strawberries and cream british in it
great everyone loves it can't go wrong
with this look how nice that looks
i'm sorry to anyone who's lactose that's
great though look look at that
see that perfect spoon i'm gonna give it
a little pre-clean
let me i hope these rubies are washing
off
yeah all right
yeah back in no summer time great watch
the tennis eat some
this this is nuts
this is nuts what are you doing to me
here this is crazy it smells really bad
genuinely doesn't smell nice that's all
right everyone for sure that's going to
be on me you know don't diss our mangoes
as
pepper mango this is crazy
there's no way i can eat that horrible
i'm definitely 100 like clear winner
hands down like this is
an easy win strawberries and cream mate
all day
that's better boom
all right licorice all sorts here i'm
not a fan of this at all my mom loves
licorice i hate licorice
ah tamarind candy or everyone for sure
that's gonna get onto me saying i don't
like these because i think everyone
likes these this is like a
celebrated thing to eat you know what
i'm saying
i don't know that's crazy because i
actually hate licorice but this is not
smelling much better i'll be honest
no that's not nice man
that is not pleasant sorry sorry sorry
it's everyone in chile i'm sorry
you want me to eat this this is horrible
i hate this hate this this is disgusting
i don't know which one's worse i'll be
honest my mom loves these and my grandma
loves these so i'm gonna be in trouble
i feel like a little kid you know when
you get vegetables a little kid i don't
want to eat
boom oh i love vimto i actually love him
so i can't lie
i love vimto vimto is great and this
solo yeah solo solos are cool
banana flavor is actually my favorite
flavor as well let's have a look let's
see
if you like don't blow and rub the top
you can what are you doing if you see
where the cans have been
get me okay i'm getting uh fruity
undertones
berries
yeah man the winter is great i love him
so one of my favorites honestly
this one this is a proper drink i can't
lie to you this is serious the uk can
take some notes
it smells banging just smells like
straight artificial banana smells great
yeah i'm banging that wins hands down
that is great
really bad the islanders your snacks
were victorious i'm aj tracy and that
was snack wars trinidad versus uk for
the lad bible you don't know
you gave me a john smith's oh my god
oh my god
oh mate i don't even need to try these
oh my god
oh it's been so long ah ah
get low there holy yoho
yeah i'm taking these from yeah yeah
yeah yeah tastes like heaven baby um